i'm reluctant to be overly judgmental
about my past but but i think you know
if i was to give advice to young people
in general i would have told myself to
not be in such a hurry like it was all
about being on this trajectory upwards
towards like a materialistic
socially approved version of success
that had no room for any kind of
introspection or
or whimsy like it never occurred to me
to think about what it is that i wanted
for myself i just like i'm here to like
check these boxes and you know go to
this college and go to the grad school
and get the job and there was no looking
in the rear view mirror let alone like
looking inward
so my advice is always like slow down
like you're like oh if i don't you know
get right in there right away i'm gonna
get
surpassed by my peers and i'll fall
behind and i'll never catch up and then
it's a failure like all of that is just
a mental construct that i think is
really damaging to young people
regardless of your lot in life or what
your career looks like or what your
you know pressures and and obligations
look like
all of us want to find a little bit more
meaning and a little bit more purpose in
our life and it doesn't have to be a
flighty thing of like you know i'm going
to quit my job like we were talking
about earlier it's just like
getting clear on what your values are
and then being really objective about
how the decisions you're making every
day are you are either lining up with
those values or aren't and working to
kind of create greater alignment between
those things
that was rich role full transparency
here i was totally intimidated to
interview him i mean he's an og
podcaster host of one of the biggest
podcasts on the planet and i'm a brand
new fake it till i make it baby at this
and he's extremely accomplished and has
had conversations with hundreds of
thought leaders and wisdom-filled people
in the off chance you don't know who
rich role is he's a graduate of stanford
university and cornell law school that
got sober after a decade of drug and
alcohol addiction and at 40 years old
walked away from his career in law to
transform and reinvent himself once he
learned the value of a healthy
plant-based lifestyle he then went on to
become a globally known vegan ultra
endurance athlete and best-selling
author who was named one of the 25
fittest men in the world by men's
fitness and the world's fittest vegan by
men's health he's a wellness advocate
father of four and globally known for
his athletic accomplishments including
being the first of two people to
complete five iron mans on five hawaiian
islands in under a week
his story has inspired millions on
addiction redemption and optimal health
i'm humbled to have gotten the chance to
sit down with and learn from someone i
admire not just as a successful
podcaster who is incredible at
cultivating meaningful conversations but
also as someone who's so driven by
learning and growth
a prime example of this is that he
mentioned in this conversation that he
doesn't consider himself an expert in
anything even with all his
accomplishments that shows how dedicated
he is to being a lifelong learner this
conversation turned into a fusion of
what we are both interested in and a lot
of it tied into mindful living practices
we talk about practicing patience and
presence in life and the journey towards
creativity
joy and finding purpose and running with
it stepping into the person you've
always wanted and deserved to be what he
does to stay motivated daily his
spiritual beliefs his parenting
philosophy and evolution over the years
now that his kids are teenagers life
lessons that have integrated into his
fatherhood role the advice he would give
his younger self as a lawyer and when he
was struggling with addiction and more
i hope you enjoy a conversation welcome
to the ellen pitcher podcast thank you
so much for coming on my podcast rich i
am so excited to have you on um you were
the first podcast i ever listened to and
my husband when he he read your book
finding ultra back when he had first
gotten plant-based because
he went plant-based and he had found
himself with the energy and the desire
to run so he just started running and he
never had found that self before and
then when your book came out he's like i
need to read this oh that's sweet well
it's really nice to be here with you
thank you for coming to my studio
not making me drive down to long beach
yeah
oh i would appreciate that i would of
course make the drive it is completely
worth it i've been i've i've wanted to
meet you for a really long time
so
something we have in common is that both
of our podcasts started in hawaii
although mine wasn't in a yurt
i started it yeah we were living in on
the north shore of kauai
in late
2012 early 2013
and we were living in europe's but the
podcast started in like a warehouse and
i didn't realize that
like the ambient noise of having like a
50 foot high tin ceiling would be a bad
idea for recording audio but
those were the humble roots and yeah i
it started really as
just a fun creative flyer it wasn't like
i'm launching a podcast i just thought
like this could be an interesting
creative thing to do and i was sort of
getting island fever out there as well
and i needed a creative outlet i had you
know pushed finding ultra into the world
and
had been thinking about what might be
next and had thought about doing a
podcast but
hadn't done anything about it and then
you know the timing was just right while
we were living out there because i was
starting to get a little stir crazy yeah
and how long were you recording out
there and what island were you on we
were on kauai uh and i was there at a
place called common ground that my
friend chris jabe had this beautiful
property that he was trying to figure
out how to develop and he brought
me and our whole family out there to
help him brainstorm what to do with this
property i don't know why he thought i
would be somebody who would be qualified
to help him with that but it was
actually amazing because we were going
through a very difficult financial
period
and he was sort of throwing us a
lifeline
so we happily went we packed up and
moved there
and we were on the precipice of losing
our house at the time so we thought
maybe we would just be living in yurts
and that was it we were going to be in
kauai that's not how it turned out but
um i really enjoyed that period of time
and it was you know kind of a beautiful
moment for our family our kids were
young
and uh
and uh yeah but i think
you know kawhi has a very specific
energy as somebody who's you know
familiar with the
vicissitudes of uh the hawaii vibe and i
think that
you know i was in a place where
i had worked really hard to kind of
create some momentum around these ideas
that i cared about and i put this book
out into the world
and i felt like i needed to be connected
to humanity in a little bit more of a
profound way than what was possible
living on this remote island and so i
was kind of it was great but then after
a couple months i was like i think we
need to go back
but the podcast was a way of kind of
mending that connection in the period of
time before we ended up returning to los
angeles yeah for sure and was that in a
period of time like you said you were on
the maybe losing your house
time in your life at what point in your
journey from you know quitting being a
lawyer and recovering from addiction was
that
so i got sober 31 so i'd been sober for
almost 10 years when i had this health
scare
and decided that i needed to kind of
rehab my lifestyle not just drugs and
alcohol
and that began this journey into fitness
and nutrition i adopted a plant-based
diet and that kind of revitalized my
health and led me into the world of
ultra endurance and i competed in these
crazy races and that
led to a little bit of media attention
because it was still early days in terms
of plant-based athlete prowess and so
people were curious about how this
middle-aged lawyer was able to like
compete at a pretty high level in his
mid-40s and doing it without animal
products and
that media attention led to this book
deal to write finding ultra i wrote that
book i was practicing law throughout
that entire period of time
in various incarnations like i had left
big law firm life and then i was a solo
practitioner and then i had a couple
partners but the truth is i was really
backpedaling out of it like i was losing
interest and i wasn't really making very
much money doing it anyway because i
wanted to do all this new stuff you know
i wrote this book while i was also
practicing law and trying to raise kids
and train for these races
and the book came out and it did well
but it wasn't a new york times
bestseller it didn't make some big
massive splash and i got a nice advance
for it but certainly not enough to
support a family of
six people for any extended period of
time
and
and uh that's what led to kind of a real
crisis of like how was i going to turn
the ideas in this book and the ideas
that i was passionate about into
something that could sustain my family
and i was in a protracted period where
like
it just wasn't happening like there's a
quote in my book
that goes like this when your heart is
true the universe will conspire to
support you and i i believe that my
heart was true and i believed that quote
and i was sort of awaiting that
universal support and it just wasn't
showing up for me and meanwhile we
couldn't pay our bills i'd let go of my
bar
membership so when my book came out i
was like i'm not practicing law anymore
like i'm all in and i believe in that
idea of
you know taking that leap of faith like
if you're straddling two worlds and you
have one foot in one thing and one foot
in the other
the more aspirational thing you're
giving mixed signals to the universe
like you're telling the universe like
i'm not really all the way in and i was
like i need to be all the way in and if
i go all the way in
then you know that net will appear and
something will
work out yeah and ultimately it did
we're sitting in my studio i can't even
believe i have the largess that i have
today it just didn't happen on the
timeline that i would have preferred and
frankly i'm all the better for it
because we really had to go through a
very hard time and i look at that period
of time as
as you know
like a rite of passage or a period of of
being made ready to carry a certain
resonance like we had to really hit a
certain kind of bottom
in order to meet ourselves and kind of
grow spiritually and emotionally so that
i would be more
capable of kind of doing what i get to
do today yeah and and so you'd be
capable to do what you love and that's
what life is all about really and so
often we get really hung up in this like
i have to do it this way this is what's
safe but by taking a risk you were able
to follow pursue what was like exciting
you in life and i really do agree with
you i believe that like when you follow
what's really exciting you you're going
to put your heart into it and the
universe will
respond to that
sure but i think it's a little bit more
nuanced than that like i i bristle a
little bit on the do what you love thing
because
there's a lot of permutations between
the nine to five job and the do what you
love like
especially when you have kids and you
have responsibilities like it doesn't
necessarily make sense for most people
under most circumstances to just say i'm
going to do what i love
that's not reality and i don't think
it's a responsible message to put that
out there like i think it's better to
have a way to make your ends meet while
on the side you're pursuing this thing
that you love until it grows to a
certain point where you can kind of
responsibly transition and i realize
that's contradictory to what i said
before about having your foot in both
worlds so maybe i'm duplicitous in in
saying that but i think that uh the
doing what you love thing
requires a lot of inner work in order to
be
mature enough to kind of manage what
that actually means in a practical way
a lot of people who haven't done enough
interior work or haven't lived enough
life or haven't met and overcome enough
obstacles
on their journey say i'm going to do
what i love but they're really not
prepared for what that actually means
and so i always like to temper that a
little bit because i also think it makes
people feel guilty who have nine to five
jobs and have some level of satisfaction
with that who then think well am i
really doing what i love like am i
missing out like i feel like i should be
you know i don't know you know doing x y
or z instead and i think it's totally
fine to be patient like i'm 55 now like
i didn't start figuring this stuff out
until
i was in my late 40s and early 50s
ultimately so i don't think there's a
big rush towards this kind of thing but
i think to be
wrestling with and reckoning with
what that thing might be that you could
fall in love with or what gets you
excited about getting out of bed in the
morning is an important exercise i just
think it's a process of incrementally
building that into your daily experience
yeah i'm really glad you said that
because of course it depends on the
situation depends on the person depends
on what's going on and it's true there's
so many nine-to-five jobs that people
really love my brother-in-law's a
structural engineer and he loves his job
there's nine to five isn't inherently
like not following your dreams or doing
what you love it's really has to do with
like
reflecting inward in how well you are
loving what you actually do and not many
people like you said are just going to
quit overnight and do something takes a
lot of risk what you just did or what
you did do a while ago and while risk is
a good thing i feel like you should have
some level of risk but it doesn't mean
you have to give everything up and like
do these huge huge amounts of risk so
like for me an example is um like my
main youtube channel i was like i'm
feeling burned out i want to start
exploring new topics have long
conversations
and explore in that way rather than like
how many different ways can i show the
green smoothie and going to the beach
and homeschooling you know i'm like i'm
ready to talk about other things and
explore other
creative outlets
but i didn't just quit that overnight
and like i'm going to start over
all brand new so
it's like a calculated response of being
willing to take risks because you know
being willing to spend more energy into
something and give my heart into it and
also you know dabble your feet in both
but then like you said what you said in
the beginning of like you you felt like
you had to give it up completely and
maybe that just depends on
where you were at your stage maybe you
didn't do that right away you were
dabbling in the other things like you're
like the podcast and you wrote your book
first before you were able to like fully
go in yeah but i did the podcast for
years and years before it generated a
penny of interest too so you know i know
totally it was hard for a minute there
but the rewards really do outweigh
all of it yeah i mean i'm incredibly
grateful to be able to you know have the
position that i have and
um
you know i'm extremely fortunate and i
think i benefited from being early in
the podcast thing
when there weren't you know
millions of people clamoring to start
podcasts all the time so i was able to
set myself up distinguish myself develop
an audience when there wasn't a lot of
competition and then just kind of hold
on to it and build upon that over the
years and also was able to kind of hone
my craft and learn how to do this when
the the risk factor was pretty low
because the audiences were so much
smaller and there weren't that many
people listening to podcasts back then
we're brought to you today by bite i'm
obsessed with bite toothpaste bits for
so many reasons not only do you avoid
the harsh chemicals artificial flavors
and preservatives that you get from
conventional toothpaste you also get to
avoid the plastic waste from using
bottled toothpaste as well that's why
bite makes toothpaste tablets made with
clean ingredients that are sulfate palm
oil and glycerin free and on top of that
the jars are so pretty it comes in
refillable glass jars and they send
refills and compostable pouches so
they're better for our bodies and our
earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it will turn into
paste just like you're used to but with
no plastic tube or messy paste which
makes it extra convenient for kids who
think popping a bite in their mouth is
so fun and makes tooth brushing time a
pleasant experience it honestly felt a
little weird at first but now my whole
family is obsessed it's so effective and
makes my teeth extremely clean i ran out
of bite toothpastes once so i went back
to my old regular toothpaste and very
quickly i realized that my teeth didn't
feel as clean so i'm never going back to
pace and will be using bite from here on
out and my holistic dentist fully
approves bite makes plastic free
alternatives for everything on your
bathroom sink so you can cut out the
harsh chemicals and plastic waste
without compromise and bite is offering
my listeners 20 off your first order go
to
trybite.com ellen or use the code ellen
at checkout to claim this deal that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e
dot com slash ellen right but for some
people even just taking the time to even
start a podcast it's a big risk like
being able to delegate their time in a
different way where they're like i'm not
making any income from this so it really
depends on well i don't think anybody
should start a podcast to make money
there's much better ways of trying to
you know yeah earn earn cash then
than starting a podcast absolutely yeah
it's really it really is much more than
that like at least for me i'm like i
love conversations and i know that you
do too and that's one reason why i'm
like sitting here like
was preparing for this like what am i
gonna ask this guy who's had hundreds of
conversations with like the most
inspiring people and done interviews and
i'm trying and i was trying to figure
out what would i like to ask you if i
was to sit down with you and i did
actually come i kept coming back to
parenting because that's the phase of
life that i'm in right now with like
really young children and i know that
your children are older so i just i
wanted to ask like what it's been like
learning from so many people all the
conversations you had and if any of that
has integrated into your parenting life
not even like a parenting episode but
just all the things you've learned and
different types of episodes and if that
has played out in your parenting life at
all yeah of course i mean it's
impossible
to not let like some of the wisdom that
i've been privileged to participate in
trickle down into how i think about
parenting and practice parenting but
it's not like oh you know susan david
was here and she talked about emotional
resilience so i'm going to build that
into it doesn't it's sort of just an
osmosis you know kind of stew of like
then how i behave around my kids and
think about how to guide them uh
appropriately but i think you know
there's some general tenants that i've
come away with we have four kids the
oldest is 20 the two older ones are my
stepsons that are 25 and 23 and we've
got a 18 year old and
a 15 year old
so they're older than your kids so i've
been but i and the older boys are my
stepsons i've been in their lives since
they were like three and four their
father passed away six or seven years
ago
um
so i've been kind of in the parenting
orbit for you know a couple decades at
this point
and you know what i've learned is every
time you think you're on top of
something like a new challenge presents
itself that uh that you weren't prepared
for like
the bar keeps getting higher and higher
and higher and that seems to be
continuing
so
i'm always cautious of
thinking that i have certain things
figured out especially when i'm on mic
and i'm you know in a position of giving
somebody advice like i'm very reluctant
to do that because i'm still very much a
learner as a parent i every time i think
i have it figured out like i said like
something else happens and i'm like well
i don't know how to do with the deal
with this issue you know i guess we're
going to have to learn but i think some
general principles that have been
helpful and this is just the philosophy
that my wife and i have adopted first
and foremost is the idea that
your kids don't come from you they come
through you and the more kids you have
you're about to have your fifth i'm sure
you're aware of this
there is a nurturing component to it for
sure but they come out who they are you
know and
your job is not to kind of uh
uh
you know force them into
some personality type or trajectory that
you
think they should be
but instead to identify
what makes them uniquely who they are
allow them the space
and the time to express themselves
naturally
figure out what inspires them and then
like rush in
to
provide them with the tools and the
resources and the guidance for them to
foster whatever that thing is like for
example i'm an ultra endurance athlete i
like to swim bike and run and i like to
be out in nature i like the beach i like
the ocean i like the mountains my kids
are all artists the two older ones are
musicians
the one
who's 18 just graduated high school
she's a visual artist a sculptor and a
painter and the youngest one is in
filmmaking and editing makes short films
all those people like to be in dark
rooms most of the day you know and
they're bored being out here in this
part of southern california where there
isn't a lot of cultural stimulus like
they would be happier if we moved to new
york city or something like that you
know yeah and like
they're not interested in anything that
i'm interested in now i could be like
well i failed as a parent because i
didn't get them to like
cooperate and participate with me in
this stuff that i care about but that's
not my job my job is to
say this is what inspires them like how
can i so mathis being a visual artist we
made sure we got her into a um
a high school for the arts it's like you
know examples like that like
if i'm pursuing
my dream my job as a parent is to help
them figure out what their dream is and
provide them with what they need to be
in the best situation to pursue
that thing so that's been a big thing
and
the other thing i know you homeschool
all your kids right so we've gone
through various iterations of
homeschooling over the years all the
kids were
homeschooled at different periods of
time throughout their life
some of them really took to it some of
them ultimately decided they wanted and
needed new structure uh more structure
um and of course no matter what you do
as a parent like and i promise you this
like 10 15 years from now your kids will
be very quick to tell you what you did
wrong why they're damaged because you
should have put them in school and if
you put them in school they would say
well why didn't you homeschool me like
they'll create their own narratives
around like
how you as a parent are you know off the
rails
so that's like another phase that that's
coming and that is on some level
inevitable and then beyond that i think
it's just making them
understand that they're safe and secure
and loved
um with the homeschool piece that was
really about
not allowing
um
like that
young phase of their lives where they
are
natural creatives natural artists
natural explorers
people who are are are just you know
curious at that phase of life to not be
corrupted by a system that is trying to
push them into a certain kind of box
right and i think
that our kids have benefited from that
experience but i will say at the same
time
that you know if i have to take
responsibility for you know certain
things that maybe i would do differently
i don't know that they were as
academically prepared for
a structured school situation as they
could have been had we done it
differently yeah because when it comes
time that they're like look i want to go
to school and you're like all right
let's take them there and then you're
comparing like where they're at
academically because that's kind of what
schools do you kind of are forced and
thrust into like the way that they do
things that sometimes they might not be
on the same level of what everyone is
expected to at that age yeah and and
then that can breed insecurity in them
or a self-esteem issue like there's a
whole sticky wicket with with all of
that so you know i think also
a lot of people myself included
parent in opposition to the way they
were parented like i have a whole story
about the way that i grew up and what
was wrong with it and i'm not going to
make that mistake so the pendulum swings
perhaps a little bit too far in the
other direction because i grew up in a
very
academically um
rigorous environment where it was all
about achievement and getting into the
right colleges and all of that and i was
able to play that game and win at that
game but there was a cost to that too
and i think i promised myself that i
would not impose that burden on my kids
but now they're like why didn't you do
you know
why didn't you do that to me yeah
exactly exactly
all right guys are you looking for more
plant-based recipes to add into your
life and nourish your family i'm doing a
special ebook promotion for my podcast
listeners to thank you for all of your
support where you can get any of my
ebooks for 15 off with the code podcast
just go to ellen fisher.com ebooks and
enter the code at checkout to get this
deal while it lasts all three of my
ebooks are filled with our family's
favorite and staple plant-based recipes
that are whole foods focused nourishing
delicious and satisfying many of these
recipes we eat on a weekly or even daily
basis and it's filled with the meals
that i found over the years to make my
family feel our best taste incredible
and most of them are quick to whip up in
the kitchen too a family favorite is the
vegan lasagna in my epic vegan cravings
ebook and also you have to make a big
batch of home-baked omega granola which
is sure to get eaten within the week
healthy hummus recipes and a totally
decadent springtime lemon poppycake
layered with strawberry jam and cream
cheese frosting made from coconut and
lemon zest that the kids love for me to
make for their birthdays the linguine
parm and veganzuki which is a chocolate
chip skillet cookie topped with the
healthiest homemade vanilla ice cream
that tastes like it's from a creamery is
to die for
and i love making for family dinner
every week the hearty red lentil chili
from the epic plant bag kid food ebook
these ebooks are 100 vegan whole foods
focused gluten-free friendly and are
instant digital downloads that can be
read on any smartphone tablet or
computer between all three ebooks i also
include practical tips encouragement
inspiring content simple swaps to
enhance the health of your meals a seven
day sample meal plan how to help your
children love fruits and vegetables
lunchbox ideas beginner vegan tips and
more and i have poured my heart and soul
into these books between all three
ebooks there's over 460 pages of content
and vibrant photography and each recipe
is filled with vibrant whole plant foods
for health and wellness in both body and
mind remember to use the code podcast at
checkout for 15 off any or all of my
ebooks i hope you enjoy them and feel
inspired to get in the kitchen to make
healthy nourishing plant-based meals
yeah so it's kind of break that way it
is kind of rigged it's like no matter
what you do because it there's either it
depends on every kid and that's that's
what goes back to the uniqueness of each
child and paying attention to that as
opposed to like focusing on our ego of
like this is the way i want to do it you
know and this is the way i want them to
turn out because every kid is different
one of your kids might love being in
school and really thriving and the other
one really like doing something
different and being more homeschooled or
being in internships and
having a different way of going about it
yeah everyone is completely different i
it's funny when i run into young parents
now and they have a a small infinite
it's their first one and they're like
we're gonna do this and this is gonna be
this school and this activity and this
after school thing and that after and
this is where you know like in five
years we're going to be doing this i was
like good luck with that
you know like that
is you know i know that you're you're
you're approaching that with the best of
intentions and nothing but love but like
when you hold on too tightly to a
certain type of trajectory that you're
forecasting for your kid you're in for a
rough ride that's a really valuable
lesson because i think even before i got
pregnant with my first one i would see
parents doing certain things and i would
say oh i would never do that i would
never do that and then here i am then i
have my kid i'm like oh i see why they
do that okay i'm actually gonna do that
right yeah you can't really have these
like ideas like you're gonna do it in a
certain way um you can you know have
that as a guideline maybe but being
willing to be flexible with each kid
goes a long way for sure
so do you and julie ever disagree on
parenting stuff and if you do how do you
handle that
we don't have fundamental disagreements
but there is attention we're very
different people
um you know julie
you know resides in the uh in the astral
plane a little bit more than i do like
i'm a very grounded practical person and
i have a robust spiritual life and
spiritual connection
but
um
but not to the extent that she
prioritizes it in her life so
she is always going to
be the person who's going to
favor
the
offbeat off-kilter
solution to whatever's ailing the kid
like
more spirituality more spiritual
connection more creativity like she
doesn't care about academics she cares
about you know esteem and making sure
that you know the kid who is
um here on planet earth with their own
divinely inspired blueprint is respected
as as you know a sentient human and
given that type of respect and i i think
that's i respect that and that's you
know i agree with that um but i think i
come in with like all right well let's
let's impose a little structure on this
like what are we actually doing and
um she's less
about the details
and more about the bigger broader
picture the unseen and i'm more about
the kind of practicality of things and i
think with that tension we always arrive
in you know a really good solution to
whatever we're contending with yeah i
used to be very resistant to different
styles of parenting even i mean the way
that you're describing doesn't even
sound necessarily different styles but
different perspectives than both having
their purpose but for me i would like
read these parenting books and you know
if my husband wasn't feeling reading to
it and i might be like well that's not
how we should do things we should do it
this way and i was really resistant to
that for a while and that that created
like a struggle dynamic and like not
being kind of on the same team to like
how are we going to move forward and i
kind of realized after a while after
having multiple conversations with
friends and just different people i
respect and look up to that like maybe
having different sets of perspectives is
actually a good thing because you can
both bring different things to the table
so we've just kind of come to that
conclusion that it's much more
harmonious now where we're like look
we're both going to handle different
situations in different ways and they're
both valuable and might be better for
each kid depending on their what they're
going through at that moment
yeah i think that that's wise and
healthy yeah
so i wanted to also get into a little
bit about like your spirituality
practice and beliefs and just like your
philosophy because i hear you bring it
up a lot about like the universe and
spirituality and i find it so
fascinating i would love to just hear
you share a little bit more in depth on
your thoughts oh wow
um yeah i don't put a label on any of
that kind of stuff so i keep it pretty
generic in terms of
how i talk about it because the way that
i think about it really doesn't allow
itself to be siloed into any kind of
particular
philosophy or
kind of sectarian
you know approach so
yes i believe that there are forces
beyond us that we can't see that that
exceed our the capacity of our five
senses to notice
um i think there's too much
uh mystery
surrounding us at all times to
believe otherwise
and i think it's been borne out in my
life many times over just
in the way that um
you know my life has unfolded like it
doesn't make any sense right yeah and i
think when we were going through our
hardest moments the solution was always
to double down
on faith and belief in spiritual
practice and gratitude and service
like when we were in our darkest moments
it's not like oh go get a job like some
practical solution it was always like
no
the solution is to go more inward and
make sure that you're really pure with
your intentions you know like that
doesn't really square with like how you
get your bills paid but honestly that
has always been
the path that has birth like all the
things that i get to do today and it's
it's easy to forget that like and if i
do get into tense moments with julie
it's because i have lost touch with that
and i get into like we have to do this
and
she's like you're forgetting like how we
got here to begin with and the same is
true in my sobriety journey like
alcoholics anonymous is a spiritual
program and spirituality is is is
central to the process of not only
getting sober but staying sober and i've
seen so many lives transformed through
people who really shoulder that
responsibility of developing a a
spiritual connection
[Music]
that it's hard for me to believe that
that reality could be otherwise so again
it doesn't fall into a particular
denominational approach
but the practice of it is
you know basically
always returning to
appreciation for the unknown a daily
meditation practice a bet a breath
practice the active meditation of the
training that i do which is really i
think of as a spiritual practice even
though it's like a physical pursuit
um
and then always
and then a gratit a formal gratitude
practice of making a gratitude list
every day
and approaching the podcast not from a
perspective of like how can i grow this
or how many people are watching and you
know
or how much money can i make out of this
but really from a perspective of service
like how can i
find the people
and tap into their wisdom in service to
an audience of people who are eager and
hungry to learn and grow and when i can
reside in that place
all of the other problems because we all
have problems in our lives and obstacles
just seem a little bit easier to manage
yeah i was listening to your um podcast
episode you went on tom i think his name
bill you is that how you pronounce his
name and you were in the beginning of
the podcast you were talking it was on
his page or his channel um you were
talking about like your different
spiritual beliefs and i find that really
fascinating i love to hear people
dabbling back and forth like were we
created with divine intention or is it
all just random and just going back and
forth because how but but it seemed as
though even if you don't believe that we
were creating with like a divine like
there's a divine or a higher power that
you could still have those same set of
beliefs and like your purpose and i just
find that really interesting going back
and forth about that yeah it was fun
having that conversation with tom
because tom's a guy who very much lives
in his head
and i know what that's like to my wife i
live in my head to guys like tom i'm
living in my heart you know so it's all
relative it's all relative
who you're talking to that's so true
yeah that's so true because i normally
consider myself as like a head decisive
person as well and then every once while
i come to these decisions that are very
heart-led and it feels so good it feels
so right and aligned whereas like my
husband might look at me like you're all
heart everything you're doing is like
heart led like let's ground and let's
think let's think twice about these
things and i'm like i'm ready to go
so it really does depend yeah yeah yeah
for sure
um if you could give yourself your
younger self any advice like a lawyer
back when you're addicted what would you
have given yourself oh my god so much
advice
i mean i get asked this question a lot
the one thing i always say first kind of
a joke is like the first thing i would
tell my younger self is
stop drinking dude you really need to
stop drinking you know i wish somebody
had intervened in you know my
alcoholic path a little bit earlier
would see would have saved me a lot of
pain and despair but that's part of what
has made me who i am you know like i
certainly i would change that but
ultimately
if i
had never had an alcohol problem or if i
um had gotten sober very young
you know i like to think that like oh i
could have been so much more productive
and centered and on a certain path
towards the things that you know i
wanted to express in the world much
earlier but maybe that wouldn't have
been the case i don't know so i'm i'm
i'm reluctant to be overly judgmental
about my past but but i think you know
if i was to give advice to young people
in general it is like
watch it watch out for the drugs and
alcohol for sure
but also i would have told myself to
not be in such a hurry like i you know
it was all about being on this
trajectory upwards towards like a
materialistic
um socially approved version of success
that had no room for any kind of
introspection or
or whimsy like it never occurred to me
to think about what it is that i wanted
for myself i just like i'm here to like
check these boxes and you know go to
this college and go to the grad school
and get the job
and there was no looking in the rear
view mirror let alone like looking
inward
so my advice is always like slow down
like you're like oh if i don't you know
get right in there right away i'm going
to get
surpassed by my peers and i'll fall
behind and i'll never catch up and then
it's a failure like all of that is just
a mental construct that i think is
really damaging to young people so
it's always encouraging now when i see
people
who decide i'm not going to go to
college
i think college is great but it's not
for everyone yeah and people who have
the courage to say like
i actually am interested in this other
thing and college is not the best route
to that like i think that that's cool in
certain circumstances or people that
take a gap year and try like i didn't do
any of those things like i think i would
have had
a much more meaningful college
experience if i had taken time off to do
that reflection to travel a little bit
to experience the world to think about
what it was that i wanted to get out of
a collegiate experience as opposed to
just you know being an athlete and
partying like i feel like i squandered a
lot of opportunities that were presented
to me that
i could have
leveraged better had i been more mature
and maturity comes with asian experience
so
patience and slowing down are a big one
and then the other thing is
living lean and investing in experience
like rather than
you know overpaying for rent and leasing
a car and you know buying a fancy suit
or whatever you know kind of goes hand
in hand with entering the work world as
a young person
like
just try to not rack up the credit card
debt and
really save your money so that you're
never stuck in a situation should it
turn out to not be as rewarding as you
would like it to be and you can pull the
eject cord and when you are facing how
to spend your resources like invest them
in
experiences not material possessions
because i think your 20s are for
experiences
that's the period of time
where
you have very little to lose like you're
not
you don't have dependents and you don't
have a mortgage and you don't have all
these other things that complicate adult
life
like take the risks then
because the risks are not as big as they
will be later on and they'll be harder
to incur for yourself once you do have
more obligations and so i think
more young people should
have as many experiences as possible
have as many different kind of jobs as
possible travel as much as possible take
those risks because i think when you
experience the world that way you do end
up being more connected to who you
really are and then ultimately you have
a better sense of where to invest your
time and energy you know on a path and
trajectory that will be more purposeful
and meaningful than it would be
otherwise
yeah totally i totally agree i feel like
it's shifted a little bit now a days
where there's not so much pressure to go
to college especially right after high
school as it was back when i was going
to college and i think it kind of stems
from like our past generation like the
parents and from when they went to
college it was a lot more beneficial to
go for to go to college and so nowadays
it's like it doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to get a job you love if
you just get a degree certainly doesn't
mean that and it's so expensive now yeah
you know and and to saddle young people
with unbelievable debt right out of the
gate is is really a crime i i actually
forces you to make these decisions that
you would never make otherwise
and you just end up in a life that you
never you know consciously chose for
yourself yeah before you're even ready i
mean when you're 18 one of the chances
you really know what you want to do for
your life and but you're kind of thrust
in this like you've got to figure it out
now and so when i went to college i was
like i guess i'll do business like i
don't know what else well it's crazy
they're like what's your major like you
have to decide what your life is going
to be like and your brain is still like
you know forming like how is anybody
supposed to know what it is they want to
do when they haven't had any worldly
life experience i know i know and it's
kind of crazy it actually is crazy and i
do think more people are talking about
it and it's not quite as like obsessed
in our culture that you have to go to
college right out of high school and
like in order for you to be a successful
person to have a college degree it's not
quite like that anymore we have so many
other types of jobs that don't require a
college degree these days um and but
there's also the financial aspect like
so many people you just think that's
what you do you graduate high school you
go to college you get this massive
amount of debt you pay off the debt for
a huge amount of time you buy the car
um to get to the job you know that whole
staying that that you're paying for the
job what you end up doing and this is
exactly what i did as a young lawyer
like it seemed like i was getting paid a
lot but any dollar that i had would go
right out the door to buy the thing that
would solve the emotional pain that i
was in from being on a career trajectory
that i [ __ ] hated like so i i'd lease
a car that i couldn't quite afford or
get the apartment that was just outside
of my budgetary ability to manage and so
i was always broke you know because i
was compensating
for being so unhappy and you know
ultimately you know the the salary keeps
increasing but you keep chasing that
thing until you know you're a partner in
a law firm and you got a couple kids and
a mortgage and you're like well i can't
get out now and i guess i'll just have
to wait until the next life and you're
just drowning in debt and look there are
people that have these jobs that love
them i'm not talking about those people
i'm talking about the people who
you know are doing it because they feel
like that's what they need to do to be
approved of or accepted by society or
you know familial pressure and all these
other things that go into how people
make career decisions yeah absolutely
there's like that saying about like
keeping up with the joneses but more
often than not the joneses are broke
because they're all keeping up with each
other and they're like oh i gotta have
that thing and so now i gotta buy this
thing and then on top of it like you
said the college debt um like the
student loans and then they're just
buying things they can't afford so
honestly there's so many people who you
would think are really wealthy but
they're actually drowning in debt and
the same goes for the opposite side
there's people that you would think they
must not have very much money but they
actually are very secure in their
finances because of how careful they
were with their money so that's why i
loved having on rachel cruz in my
podcast if anybody watching or listening
is dave ramsey's daughter and all about
financial freedom and what like their
biggest slogan is like live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else and that has been like
just something that my husband and i
just really get excited about because i
love i'm just like really into
short-term really hard work for
long-term success and gains and so that
also goes for short-term sacrifice for
long-term gains because if you're
willing to sacrifice yeah you're not
going to get the car you want by the buy
the cheapest car you that you can pay
cash for doesn't mean you're going to
have that car for the rest of your life
it's just like looking ahead and not
feeling like you have to just have
all the things that everyone else around
you seems to have well the more content
you are in how you spend your time
throughout the day
the less pull or the less of lure
the fancy car and all that other stuff
holds over you yeah at least in my
experience it's like
when i'm really happy when i with what
i'm doing for a living or how i'm
spending my time and the people that i'm
spending it with i don't end up thinking
about that kind of stuff but i'll catch
my like if i'm having a bad day i'll be
like oh i think the solution to my
problem would be if i bought that thing
that i just saw on that ad on instagram
you know it's like that's a good
indication to me that i'm kind of off my
game
yeah and one of the things you mentioned
earlier about the
like you're going to not fall in your
parents footsteps like i'm not going to
do it that way it just wasn't about my
parents at all but i grew up in orange
county where it's like quite
materialistic driven and there was a lot
of pressures to like have the nice
things or i felt that as a teenager
right maybe it was self-inflicted
because my husband also grew up in
orange county and he didn't feel those
pressures so it really just depends on
who you're hanging around and you know
what your life story is but as i got
older i was like well i would love for
my kids to not feel those pressures
growing up so that was one of the
reasons why we packed up and moved to
hawaii because i was like i want to
raise my kids barefooted in the
waterfalls and not have so much emphasis
on like the nice car and the like
expensive purses and all the things that
i felt this pressure that i needed to
have to feel valuable in high school so
that was for sure one of them and one of
the things about like the purpose stuff
you were talking about earlier you
recently had someone on your podcast and
there was a quote i think that was
saying something about the meaning of
life is finding your purpose and then
the purpose of life is to live out that
purpose is that
something like that yeah or to give it
away
or to give it away that was chip conley
yeah and if we had like more of a
mentality to raise our kids in such a
way that like after high school there
isn't so much pressure to like go and be
successful go and graduate college so
you can
you know get the good job and get all
the money instead more having like a
message of like finding what you're good
at that you love yeah and i think
you know i got some pushback from that
conversation there was a certain cohort
of people that thought it was elitist
you know to suggest such an idea like oh
how privileged are you that you can
entertain
like whether or not your life has
purpose and meaning like i'm just trying
to put food on the table for my kids and
i so i think it you know there is some
sensitivity around that and i would
address that by just saying like it
doesn't it's it it's not an elitist
thing in the sense that regardless of
your lot in life or what your career
looks like or what your
you know pressures and and obligations
look like
all of us want to find a little bit more
meaning and a little bit more purpose in
our life and it doesn't have to be a
flighty thing of like i'm moving to
hawaii or i'm doing you know i'm going
to quit my job like we were talking
about earlier it's just like getting
clear on what your values are and then
being really objective about how the
decisions you're making every day are
there are either lining up with those
values or aren't
and working to kind of create greater
alignment between those things so
if you're working two or three jobs and
you've got you know a bunch of kids like
your life is hard you know so you don't
have the luxury of like well i guess i'm
gonna you know i need more purpose in my
life you know it's like yeah yeah you
know tell that to somebody who's like
having that kind of real world struggle
and they're gonna you know be pissed off
for good reason so
you know i am sensitive to that but i
think that nonetheless
they can still find you know
a way to mine that purpose and meaning
within the constraints of uh you know of
their their very real world pressures i
totally agree i'm really not a fan of
that type of mentality as much and you
know i think it's really good to be
sensitive to it and pathetic to
everyone's stories being completely
different right like no set of
conversations going to be able to relate
to everyone because everyone's having a
different experience in life and but the
difference between taking someone else's
experience and what they've learned from
like this person that you interviewed
and saying
maybe i could find a little glimpse of
inspiration from that like what can i
what can i do to reach that a little bit
more or does that inspire me in any way
or you could just be like take it or
leave it that's how he feels but then
there's the other way of like well i
could never do that and and there's no
way i could do that so you shouldn't say
it at all to me i feel like does a huge
disservice to us as people being able to
try to understand each other and be able
to just be inspired by each other
instead of um like there's there's a
difference between being a victim and
having a victim mentality in life and so
to me
i feel like that's really great one of
the reasons why you're such a great
podcaster because you're able to think
about all the different people's
situations and caring about their own
experiences and how they're going to
receive what you're saying that's like
one of the best parts about being a good
conversationalist when you're speaking
to a lot of people
but then there's also like you can take
it and empathize and then you can also
be willing to be like well but is that
really the best for us to say maybe we
shouldn't say that at all like that's
elitist because someone can't
experience something yeah i mean i i
there's a saying in recovery like are
you looking for the similarities or are
you looking for the differences so like
when you attend like a 12-step meeting
and you hear somebody share their story
you could say well that person's nothing
like me
or you can say oh that person said a
couple things that i actually relate to
and it's really a perspective shift
um
because if you're really listening and
paying attention you can probably
identify
some aspect of yourself
in everybody's story but somebody who is
looking at it through that perspective
of looking for the differences is gonna
have that like
negative view of a lot and there's a
weird thing on the internet right now
where it's like
oh well if if i can't like if i don't
see myself in this person that i'm
listening to or looking at like i don't
like them and how dare you
how dare you platform somebody who like
i can't relate to and it's it's like
okay but like can you find a way to
relate to them or not everybody can
relate to everybody like i'm i have 700
podcasts up i'm sure you can find
somebody that you can relate to exactly
but the question is always like are you
looking for the differences or are you
looking for the similarities are you
looking for
for you know because sometimes it's it's
more comforting to say well i can't
relate to that person so i can't do that
now i don't have to really be honest
with myself or make any kind of
fundamentals or any change and you
shouldn't even say it like because it's
scary to say like oh my goodness i
actually see a kernel of truth and what
that person's saying and now i have to
look at myself
and do an inventory and figure out how i
can make
a little bit of that change in my own
life and that's hard it is now and so
especially it's not surprising that
people are gonna like put up a wall
because no one wants to change i don't
want to change the only thing that's
ever gotten me to change is like being
in a tremendous amount of pain so
you know i get it i guess yeah a lot of
times the change is most likely to
happen when you're at like your lowest
low you have nowhere to go but up right
you have no choice yeah uh i think it
reminds me of another of an example
that's similar to that like when i had
done like a po i had done like a post
about postpartum and like look these are
the best tips i've found to recover the
quickest to find the most healing and
the easiest bond with my baby and i'm
sharing things like stay in bed all day
if you can right let people take care of
how nice for you i know okay
i mean but really you will heal so much
faster as an example like from birth if
you're willing to let people take care
of you because a lot of people do
struggle to let people help them some
people struggle to receive help right
and so it was like a message of just
like lay in bed and bond with your baby
and let people take care of you things
like eating enough calories and things
like that and there was some pushback
again kind of like that like well not
everybody has that luxury
and that's true not everybody does there
are single moms out there who are really
just and they have multiple kids and
they have to get up they can't just go
lay in bed um but again going back to
the like what kernels of truth can i
take from that that i could potentially
be willing to do to get a little bit of
that if i'm even inspired by that maybe
you're not inspired by it and that's
okay
um but if you're inspired by that you
could be like who can i reach out to and
ask for help is there anybody in my life
that i am will that i can do that and be
vulnerable and ask for help and that's
just another example like kernels of
truth versus taking something be like
well i'm never going to get that so how
do you even insinuate that other people
can do that well we also live in a
culture where asking for help is
considered a weakness and we've moved so
far away from it takes a village to this
idea of rugged individualism
that
we're meant to feel like we're a failure
if we can't take care of all of this on
our own and like child rearing should be
you know a team sport you know
like
not that long ago you know small
villages where everybody's relatives and
grandparents and great grandparents all
lived in you know a
four block radius and everybody helped
with everyone and now we're in sconced
in cul-de-sacs and suburbs and we feel
like we can't measure up if we we meet
these problems and it's like it's not
okay to ask for help and it's like we
all need help but it's scary to ask for
help it's scary yeah yeah we don't live
in a in a in a culture that's really
permissive in that regard i think yeah
absolutely we're so separated and the
way our society is kind of like building
upon itself as making it harder and
harder to stay connected and so just
getting back to that roots of being
willing to ask your help ask for help is
something that is really hard for some
people but worth it
so what do you do then it sounds like to
me even this conversation
about um how you can take take messages
from other people and find the good in
it where can i find common ground i feel
like that is a form of unlocking your
best self even if you can only take
little
little kernels from it and you can't
take the whole thing like well i can't
do all that right now but i can do
something from that are there any what
other i mean of course there's other
things what's another thing that you do
in it as like a weekly practice or a
habitual practice to unlock like your
your best self because clearly a lot of
people look up to you and are inspired
by you because of what you've done and
your journey so yeah i would love to
know if there's what else yeah i don't
i feel like you're asking for like a tim
ferriss type like here's my routine and
i do these things every day
like i don't really function like that i
just i don't think of myself as an
authority on
unlocking your best self like i feel
like i'm
i'm with the audience in that like i'm
on this journey just like you and i'm a
deeply flawed human being who screws up
all the time and i have done some
interesting things but all that's done
is allowed me to see how much growth
remains and so
the people that i select to come on the
show are often people who are offering
some wisdom on something that i'm
struggling with in the moment like or an
idea that i'm grappling with like the
chip conley conversation and arthur
brooks who i just had on
both our authorities on like how to
think about our later decades and find
meaning in them and as a 55 year old
dude who's you know suddenly going gray
everywhere like i can't help but think
like
how long am i going to do this podcast
and like
if i were to just turn it off tomorrow
would i have an identity crisis would i
be okay with myself like these are
things i'm thinking about and grappling
with and i need that mentorship and that
counsel and that guidance so
you know this is an ongoing kind of like
therapeutic modality for me that i get
to share with other people
um
but in terms of like what i do every day
i mean exercise is non-negotiable like
that's part of my you know mental health
routine as much as it is
for my physical health
and i have a practice of not
scheduling anything before noon like
noon
no phone calls no zoom calls no
nothing like that's my time and i'm very
privileged to be able to do that being a
self-employed person and i understand
that but that's my time that's my time
for creativity and for physical exercise
so it's me you know and it's not the
same every day and i have four kids and
things intervene and i don't always i'm
not always it you know perfectly able to
adhere to that rule but by and large i
do adhere to it and that gives me the
space to explore ideas to write to
journal to meditate to train
um
it's self-care you know in various ways
um
and i protect that fiercely that time
and how you because this is something i
grapple with when it comes to having
young kids that i'm just i'm always
wanting to be a part of all of it all at
once like i want to just be with my kids
100 of the time and just spend all my
quality time with them and just do
homeschooling with them and do all of it
right but then i also really love this
work that i'm doing i really love the
podcast i really love
you know all the things that i do on my
social media and i want to create a
pregnancy course and there's all these
things i want to do and it's like
finding the time for not necessarily
even the word balance because i've heard
even i've heard you talk about the word
talk about balance and how like
sometimes your biggest your best
achievements have been when you're out
of balance i so find that true because
i mean this week is an example i'm i
have been spending all week just like
buckling down getting as much done as i
can because to me it's like that short
term hard work for the long-term gain
and then i can relax once i get it all
done but there is a form of balance i
think when it comes to raising kids so
how do you find that pursuit of
following your passions and doing the
stuff that you love but also getting
that time with your kids maybe it's
different now that they're a little
older yeah but now they don't want
anything to do with me right now it
makes it easier but when they were
younger yeah and it's not like just as a
caveat like in that you know period of
time before noon i'm not i'm not like
ignoring or just yeah
it's like they're part of this yeah no i
thought i thought that question because
you mentioned your kids yeah you know i
think it's tricky you know i do hate
that word balance uh yeah i think it
makes people feel miserable about their
lives
because nobody can live up to this
imagined idea of living a balanced life
i'm a i'm an extreme personality and so
i vacillate between
you know extreme pursuits
the pendulum swings but it always swings
back it's got to swing to normal you
know or middle and over the course of a
long period of time my life does come
into balance it's just not
in balance on a day-to-day basis and
right i
rather than focusing on balance i think
i like to think about presence like
are you present for whatever it is that
you're doing right now are you bringing
all of yourself
to whatever it is that you're doing in
the moment
and i think in terms of child rearing
there's the impulse to always be with
your kids but ultimately
you can't be
the best parent
you possibly can be
if you're allowing your life to be
subsumed by your children like you your
kids like they see everything you know
and if they see
you uh like like sort of projecting your
identity onto them that's not a healthy
thing the hovering the like it's gonna
be exactly this way right and just you
know basically like yeah just basically
attending to their every little need 24
7 is not healthy for them and also they
see a parent who has no life outside of
them you know that's not good either you
have to have something outside of that
that gives you sustenance and
fulfillment and you have that it just
has to be calibrated responsibly so that
your kids needs are being met while your
needs are also being met and you know
i'm sure on a day-to-day basis your
needs aren't getting met on some days
and on other needs like you weren't able
to do the one thing for your kid that
you wish you could have because you're
sitting here with me right now
but
the question i would have for you is
when you're sitting here doing this with
me are you thinking about all the things
you should be doing with your kids that
you're not doing right now or are you
present for having this experience like
are you beating yourself up because you
can't be in two places at the same time
like that's that becomes like
you know a dark slippery slope for a lot
of people yeah and it's and i grapple
with it too like
you know i want to be the present dad
who's there for every single thing and
you know i can't always be that person
but i'm there
you know for for basically almost
everything like in the grand scheme of
being a dad like
and being self-employed like i have the
fortune of being you know i'm i could be
around for basically everything that i
need to and want to be around for yeah
and when you are present in whatever you
are doing you're going to be a lot more
productive and it's not only just
productive but it's going to be a lot
more meaningful as well as opposed to
having this looming you have all these
other things in the background you got
to be doing and i think that is a
temptation for a lot of parents when
they're with their kids especially
they're with their kids and they're like
i got all this other stuff i gotta do i
gotta do all these things instead of
like being present with you yeah it's
not about the quantity of time it's
about the quality of the time that you
actually have so you can spend all day
with them but if you're on your phone
the whole time like were you ever really
were you even with
and conversely
like i'm not going to feel guilty when i
want to go out and do a two-hour trail
run like i need that for myself
without that i can't be the best parent
that i can be like i mean you know and
so it's sort of about respecting
respecting those things and and having
like healthy boundaries around the
things that you need to do for yourself
that are that are meaningful that allow
you to be the best version of who you
are i think with this type of like solo
entrepreneur thing like it's nothing
it's never done like you're never like
well it could bleed into everything yeah
yeah you can bleed into everything and
then you're always kind of doing it
without and you're kind of always doing
it and not really ever doing you're like
it's just
and that's dangerous right and your kids
will feel that energy shift so you have
to have boundaries around that stuff
yeah absolutely the boundaries instead
of like focusing on so much about
balance like i got to have equal time
and all these things it's more about the
boundaries and the presence i totally
see that that makes a lot of sense
so what is the best advice that you've
been given lately then in all these
lessons that you learned from
conversations oh man
that's really putting me on the spot the
best advice that i've been given with
all the conversations you have
um
that's really hard
it's funny because i have all these
conversations and then people will say
remember when you were talking to that
guy and he said this and you said that
i'm like no i don't remember that like i
i have the podcast and then it's kind of
out of my conscious memory and it just
goes into my unconscious experience so
it's hard for me to recall like oh
so-and-so said this and it changed my
life it's more about like what am i
contending with now and i think
referring again to like chip and arthur
my two most recent guests on this
subject of like finding meaning as we're
getting older there's this idea like
there's an inevitable decline like you
know i'm going to snap my fingers i'm
going to be 60 right like is my brain
gonna still work okay am i going to be
able to like do what i do
um yeah because you always thought once
i got to 60 like who even knows what i
would be doing well like will anyone
care like who's going to want to hear
from me you know and like how do i
prepare for that
and i think what was profound about what
both of them said is that will happen so
rather than being in denial about it
like start thinking about how you can
[Music]
you know
continue to iterate and pivot on what
you do so that you're prepared for that
and a lot of that has to be has to do
with
being in this service mode of like
giving back like being what what uh chip
calls a modern elder like you know like
which is basically like
shifting from being a high performer
into kind of a mentor for younger people
just like
just like tom cruise and top gun he's
maverick in the first one but then he
comes back he's still awesome but he's
really kind of mentoring this next crop
of of fighter pilots have you seen the
new top gun my husband has my i'm
looking like headlights my husband is
the king in this movie but like i was
like oh tom cruise is becoming a modern
elder like so that's kind of like where
my head is at right now
um
in terms of how i'm thinking about like
the next chapter of my life yeah then
like looking at what's next so being a
modern elder then is essentially do you
feel like it's like passing down what
you've learned yeah yeah and it's that's
there's a discomfort with that too
because i never put myself in the in the
position of authority like i rarely
give advice like i answer listener
questions on occasional podcast episodes
but i'm not the guy on instagram or on
the internet or on youtube saying here
are the three things you need to do like
it doesn't feel comfortable to me to do
that like i still think of myself as a
learner but i have accrued some wisdom
and i think there is a way to you know
share that in in a meaningful way i
think it can be both
that yeah we'll see we'll see what
happens you can be both a learner and
share what you've learned yeah i like
but i like having guests on my podcast
and having them tell me yeah no tell me
so maybe there's a little bit of a
shadow like insecurity there or
something like that yeah because i mean
if you know that there's like a shred of
truth to somebody else being being able
to like share wisdom than what's
limiting you from being able to do that
too yeah i don't know i should i should
look into that contemplate that yeah
some subconscious thing that that maybe
you're not i don't know worthy enough to
be able to have wisdom for someone else
to take it and receive in a way that's
going to benefit their life which is
funny because this is like what your
whole podcast is like you're like you i
know that you're interviewing other
people but you're bringing that to life
because of the conversations you're
having
right but i'm doing it as a as like a
vector for it as opposed to like the
person who's
looking to camera and telling you how it
is right but i think that even is
fascinating in itself because i think
correct me if you think i'm wrong that a
lot of podcasters might be getting into
it be like look i'm going to tell you
guys what you need to know i'm going to
have on guests that are going to tell
you what i already know but you need to
know instead you're going into it being
like what can i learn
from this person yeah which is why it's
hilarious when i see all these 25 year
old life coaches like trying to tell you
how to fix your life and i'm just like
oh my god
that's an interesting concept like
you're sitting here as like at the age
that you are being like i feel like i
still can't even do that yeah i don't
feel qualified to give people advice
like that so i just like i'm like wow
i gotta respect the balls on you know
people who are like i'm gonna tell you
what to do but i mean it's very
interesting because everybody's
situation is different just that's that
going back to again why i think that
you're such a great podcaster because
you're willing you're able to see that
like look there's not one lens
everybody's walking through life with
their different lenses and their
different stories so like one piece of
advice that's gonna necessarily benefit
everybody
yeah i mean that's true i mean the
longer
the longer you're around the more you
realize everything is more nuanced and
complicated than you once believed it to
be and i think there's a humility with
that and that's something i've also
learned in sobriety like you learn to
um
you learn to approach people from a
perspective of non-judgment like far be
it for me to judge this person's
opinion because i haven't lived their
life experience you know so they are
coming into you know whatever they're
saying from a particular set of
experiences that like i
you know i don't have experience with
that so who am i to judge or
take that person's inventory and so i
think that that has
allowed me to
[Music]
in the podcast like be
open-minded but also
create a space
that's safe for people to be vulnerable
themselves and you know express their
their point of view without fear of of
like reproach or redress at least from
me yeah or judgment because so much of
what we're kind of taught and told in
society is like very black and white
like you're either right wrong good bad
wrong like evil you know all that aspect
if you don't think like i do and it
completely takes away the gray and so
much i think
of that would disappear for there would
be more conversations with differing
opinions and just trying to listen to
understand why someone thinks the way
that they do instead of like labeling oh
they think this way so they're this you
mean having a conversation with somebody
who disagrees with you yes how dare you
yes i mean to be honest i want to do a
lot more episodes on like opposing views
conversations not to necessarily be like
who's right who's wrong who was the
winner more just like can we find common
ground can we at least understand why
the other side thinks the way that they
do because so often it's like look this
is the side and they're listening to all
the things telling them that this is the
answer but they're not listening to the
other side they don't even know why the
other side thinks the way that they do
which i think does a huge service to
humanity
yeah but you need good faith actors for
that most people who
who you know say yes to those kinds of
debates already know all the arguments
on the other side and so
they're they can hear them but they're
really not listening or considering them
yes um it's very rare it's really hard
to move the needle on somebody who is an
advocate for a particular point of view
or a cause
because they're experts in debate you
know and so they're approaching it from
a perspective of winning
not compromise nuance or listening well
it depends on the person it's not
necessarily always but yeah a lot of
times if someone's willing to go into a
debate because there's that ego of like
i gotta make sure that i you know to
show that it that i'm right but even if
that's the intention i think of the
debaters i still think it's really
helpful for the listeners to hear both
sides of the argument because a lot of
times you're only listening one side i
agree with you yeah and so that's kind
of my favorite thing that i love to
discuss have you ever done any kind of
conversations with like a viewpoint that
you're like going into it like on the
podcast that you're like
maybe expecting to disagree with them
but then at the end of it you're kind of
like wow i really see their point of
view i guess i would say that i don't
um i don't like court
people who are really far afield of my
perspective
um i mean i everybody that you're gonna
say if you talk to anybody long enough
you're gonna have stuff that you
disagree with and that you agree with
everybody yeah i you know i'm very open
to like
having conversations with people that
have different
world views but i'm also
conscious of not now that my platform is
as large as it is
to not be like i don't like that word
platforming i don't know if there's
another phrase for it but you know i
have to be i think that the internet is
very unforgiving right now and i i found
myself much more conscious
in terms of who i select to to be in
conversation with
do you think that that's a good thing or
are you finding that something i think
it's good and bad i think it's i think
there's a lot of value in having
somebody on who has a very different
point of view
but i also
am trying to like i have a very specific
intention which is like i'm trying to
raise the vibration of people's yeah you
know world life experiences and and so
i'm curating a series of conversations
that i think are conducive to that yeah
um
and a conversation that
is with somebody who believes something
very differently from me i mean it would
have to be i would need a specific
example to illustrate it i guess but um
you know often then off more often than
not like that where is that really going
yeah i but honestly i really have found
and because i actually i love to seek
out conversation with people with
different opinions just like on one on
one not like something publicly but more
often than not people um feel
uncomfortable and anxious to get into
that type of conversation it depends on
the person obviously and everyone saw
find someone that really enjoys just not
a debate not a who wins who's who's
right who's wrong what more can i see
where you're coming from and more often
that it's just even if you're not going
to change your mind on your opinion you
just start to relate to them a little
more and you see sure why that they do
sure anyways so uh one of the last
things i wanted to ask you was or just
talk about which is kind of a theme that
you've talked about is like throughout
this episode is about success being
different than what you originally
thought and i saw you posting earlier
about like your book and how when it
first came out it wasn't like a number
one bestseller you said that even
earlier in this episode but over time
it's become successful and every year
you said it's getting more than it got
the last year so what can you speak to
about like for people who are looking to
have like a certain path in life but
like maybe it's not going to turn out
the way you hope yeah i mean i think it
goes back to patience you know like
every success that i've had in my life
it has been kind of illustrative of
being an ultra endurance athlete like an
ultra if you're to be successful as an
ultra endurance athlete you don't have
to go fast you just have to keep going
and i have a friend who's a screenwriter
his name is sasha gervasi he's written a
lot of like big hollywood movies
and he told me a long time ago he's like
the screenwriter that becomes successful
is the one that just doesn't stop
writing like you finish a script you
start the next script you don't wait
until you sell the script and see how it
does like you're a writer you just write
you know and if you just keep doing it
eventually something will work out
and i think right now it's important in
this very fast-paced culture where
everyone's trying to like you know score
right out of the box like
is this who you are like is what you're
doing a reflection of your identity
because if it is
the externalities of it shouldn't really
matter because this is who you are and
this is what you do
so my success as an athlete like i was a
swimmer in college i did okay but i
didn't reach my peak as an athlete until
i was like 44 you know like it's
ridiculous right and so you know the
success of finding ultra really didn't
become
evident until many years after its
publication as it's continued to find
audiences and this podcast similarly
like it took years and years and years
to get it to a place
of of you know modest relevance and now
i have the platform that i have today
but i didn't have a viral moment there
hasn't been any crazy spikes and it's
the furthest thing from something that
happened overnight like i'm in this fall
it'll be 10 years that i've been doing
this
so i'm just a huge believer
in
in focusing on the tiny little things
that you can do every single day
anonymously
um because those are really what move
the needle and determine your success or
failure like if you're in it for or you
get just you get discouraged because a
year into some pursuit like you're not
getting the results that you would like
to me i think we
far over index on what we're capable of
accomplishing in a year
and totally underestimate what we're
capable of doing over the course of a
decade it's just as human beings it's
hard for us to really
grok or contemplate like a decade
but if you think of it like okay here's
my instead of a new year's resolution
you say this is my thousand day plan
like
thousand days that's like
three years right so if you think of
like everything you can do over the over
a thousand days like
it's just a better window
from my perspective of approaching and
accomplishing goals so break these
things down into
the tiniest little habits adopt them one
by one until they become rote and second
nature and just continue to build and be
patient and when you screw up or you
move backwards it's just information to
grow and learn and continue to iterate
and as long as you stay in the game and
you continue to
mine it for meaning and purpose and all
of these things that really give you
sustainable sustenance because the
externalities are unsustainable
sustenance like you get this flash of
like excitement but that quickly wanes
if you're not really in it for the right
reasons
absolutely especially if you're talking
like monetary versus something like
you're
like a true joy in what you're doing and
yeah because success is different for
everybody sure yeah that's awesome
thanks so much for sharing all that and
for coming on my podcast i am absolutely
completely honored that you have come on
and i know my sister's so excited
because she's a huge fan
and she's been
watching you since the first days of
your podcast in hawaii so what's her
name hannah hi hannah yes how come
you're not here i'm disappointed i know
they just moved to boise idaho that's
why i know
um well an absolute pleasure and delight
thank you and i feel like we talked
about a bunch of stuff that i don't talk
about yeah that was fun yeah awesome
well thank you so much and we're signing
off
[Music]